[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno yo venía aquí con una idea y con
un discurso y como la vida es como es
que a veces es fantástica a veces no
tanto
hace un par de horas ha tenido una
llamada
con mi madre porque mi madre existe
que lo ha cambiado todo con lo cual lo
que traía preparado ya no existe y voy a
improvisar
me ha dado cuenta de que no es baladí
que el título de esta destete dexia
inexacta porque durante muchos años he
sido inexacto por no decir mentiroso y
eso es algo que me ha dicho mi madre hoy
esto va a ser un poco complicado ya os
lo digo así que preparamos un poquito
porque no va a ser fácil ni para mí ni
para vosotros ahora os vais a reír
cuando terminéis no os vais a reír
[Música]
el silencio como ha dicho mi presentador
en mi caso es muy importante y hoy va a
ser súper importante esto va a ser un
ejercicio de confianza ciega de vosotros
hacia mí y de mí hacia vosotros yo estoy
muy acostumbrado a hablar en público
pero hoy va a ser como si lo hiciera por
primera vez porque os voy a contar mi
verdad
mi madre ha cerrado la conversación
diciendo
qué maravilloso sería si siempre
pudiéramos decirnos la verdad y yo me he
dado cuenta de que llevo muchos años no
diciéndole la verdad esa verdad es la
que os voy a contar hoy y para eso
necesito dos cosas y les voy a pedir
encarecidamente una vamos a escuchar
vamos a pasar por esto con los ojos
cerrados todos quiero que cerráis los
ojos porque si no me vais a escuchar
desde un punto donde yo no quiero que
estéis tengo que confiar en que vais a
cerrar los ojos porque yo también los
voy a cerrar no puedo estar observando y
mirando uno por uno y cerrar los ojos
serrat todas nuestras pantallas cerrarlo
todo
yo cierro mis ojos en este momento
espero que hagáis lo mismo os voy a
contar cuál es mi verdad
yo soy me vais a oír temblando la voz
porque esto es verdad la voz tiembla
cuando es verdad
me han preguntado muchas veces cuando
empecé a contar
y un 22 siempre llevo 20 años mintiendo
llevo 20 años diciendo lo que se espera
oír de mí os voy a contar cuál es la
verdad de por qué empecé a contar y
cuando empecé a contar y empecé a contar
a la edad de 7 años
a los siete años de los siete a los ocho
años yo sufría abusos por parte de un
docente religioso fueron abusos
continuados fueron abusos integrales
y duraron un año entero un curso escolar
yo conocía el infierno a los siete años
hubo desgarro hubo dolor hubo daño hubo
cosas irreparables y hubo infierno fue
el infierno más absoluto
cuando esto empezó
yo rezaba yo cerraba los ojos y rezaba
y rezaba muy rápido porque creía que si
rezaba muy rápido alguien en algún lado
me iba a escuchar más rápido y eso iba a
terminar antes y nunca termino nunca
sirvió rezaba y rezaba y rezaba e rezaba
y nunca terminaba
al cabo de muy poco tiempo aprendí a ser
árbol decidí que si me convertía en un
árbol mientras esto ocurría los árboles
no sienten con lo cual si tenía una
corteza muy fuerte no iba a sentir
físicamente el dolor
funcionó pero el dolor no es sólo físico
con lo cual
tuve que inventar algo para no para
dejar de estar presente y como vi que
rezar
nos servía un día empecé a contarme una
historia
empecé a contarme la historia que a mí
me habría gustado que me contarán sobre
mí en ese momento
y en ese momento aprendí que ya no
estaba en el cuerpo que estaba siendo
abusado
ese día es el primer día en el que yo
construye una historia y me contó una
historia
cuando yo llegué a casa
me encontré a mi madre recuerdo que mi
madre estaba planchando y escuchando la
radio
y yo empecé a contarle esta historia no
sé por qué en vez de saludarla en vez de
darle me senté a su lado y empecé a
contarle la historia que yo había
inventado sobre mí y cuando termine ella
me miró y me dijo
tú de mayor serás escritor
durante un año inventé historias entre
historias porque tenía miedo de que ella
se diera cuenta de que yo estaba
conociendo el infierno entonces de
camino a casa yo repasaba la historia la
enriquecía y cuando llegaba a casa me
sentaba con mi madre y le contaba una
nueva historia y ella era tan feliz yo
aprendí a que existía la felicidad en el
otro a través de las historias que le
contaba mi madre
y eso fue un año terminó el año
yo tenía ocho años
crecí mi adolescente joven mayor y llegó
a la escritura cuando yo empecé a
escribir
me convertí en el escritor de la
oscuridad
oscuridad porque yo solo puedo escribir
con los ojos cerrados no puedo escribir
con los ojos abiertos
cuando yo era niño a los 7 años
y termino mi infierno salí de el
desencajado salí de él como un farero
ciego yo reparto
luz pero la sacó de dentro hasta
quedarme sin por eso escribo con los
ojos cerrados y
lo que aprendí escribiendo es que
escribo para mi madre
eso lo he aprendido con el tiempo yo
escribo mis novelas para ella porque sé
que la única forma de que
los fantasmas y los monstruos no existan
es cerrando los ojos entrando en el
mundo que yo creo y hablándole y
contándoselo a ella hoy lo he sabido
ella no sabe esto que estoy contando hoy
lo sabrá o en algún momento lo sabrá
espero poder contárselo antes
pero también he sabido algo hoy y es que
no solamente escribo para ella sino que
escribo para que no se muera porque
después de haber conocido el infierno y
después de haber conocido el alivio a
través de la escritura también me he
dado cuenta de que
cuando ella ya no esté
tengo miedo de que no haya nadie a quien
poder contarle mis historias
esto es un poco complicar lo que estoy
diciendo
lo que quiero deciros es lo siguiente y
esto es la segunda parte de mi charla
seguramente hay aquí hombres y mujeres
chicos y chicas que han conocido el
infierno también en algún momento de su
vida cuando eran pequeños y que son
niños desencajados seguimos siendo niños
desencajados y seguimos siendo niños que
habitan en una campana de cristal que
cuando tendemos la mano no hay calor al
otro lado no hay piel sino que hay
cristal porque el enemigo está en la
intimidad no en la oscuridad
os voy a decir algo y os voy a pedir
algo encarecidamente contarlo y contarlo
contaros lo no hace falta que lo contéis
delante de 1200 personas como yo lo
estoy haciendo con los ojos cerrados
porque no sería capaz de hacerlo con los
ojos abiertos pero contados lo
contado solo al espejo contados en la
oscuridad no hace falta que se lo
contéis a nadie pero no hace falta que
sigáis
anidados allí dentro no hace falta
porque no sois culpables de eso contarlo
y contarlo porque una voz más otra voz
más otra voz más otra voz forman una
música y esa música quizá pueda cambiar
algo en algún momento quizá sí o quizá
no pero hay que intentarlo yo intento
cambiarlo cuando escribo yo estoy
aterrado porque creo que llegará un
momento en que ya no podré seguir
escribiendo porque mi campana se cerrara
sobre mí espero que no os pase a
vosotros y espero aunque si hacemos eso
si seguimos con las voces si lo contamos
aunque no aunque sea a nadie en
particular
y el día en que esa música
consiga
que en el mundo
ojalá no vuelva a ver nunca más un
alejandro palomas encima de un escenario
[Aplausos]